[Music]
hi everyone its charlie everyone was
going crazy about this mystery
spider-man for teaser that Marvel
tweeted it out çb Sapolsky who's the
editor-in-chief of Marvel Comics is like
you guys will never believe what's going
on with this no one will ever figure it
out it's gonna be so huge Alex Ross the
artist who did the opening titles for
the first couple of spider-man films
tweeted this picture out of spider-man
and Mary Jane swinging with the
spider-man for hashtag so it only fanned
the flames there were so many theories
so we'll break it all down no worries if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos we're doing the IMAX ticket
giveaway for spider-man far from home
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this Q all the
spider-man Tobey Maguire memes you can
find we got it back when Tom Holland was
first cast back in Civil War Tobey
Maguire reacting to Tom Holland in
Captain America Civil War then Andrew
Garfield reacting to Tobey Maguire
reacting to Tom Holland in Captain
America Civil War it's only gun crazier
because of spider-man into the spider
verse and all the barriers that that
broke oh wow you can't actually do this
weird crazy multiverse story so anytime
there's a teaser about multiverse
related spider-man stuff people always
start posting Tobey Maguire spider-man
memes so on Father's Day this past
weekend on Sunday of all days Marvel
tweeted out this four people went crazy
leading theories that it's a comic book
thing it's a spider-man Fantastic Four
crossover other theories that they're
retelling Tobey Maguire's story of
spider-man for that cancelled movie in a
comic book people went crazy about that
I actually have part of the script for
that that I'll read in a second we
actually know what that movie was
supposed to be then there are people
that thought that it was a countdown for
something else it's not a Fantastic Four
crossover and it's not a retelling of
Tobey Maguire's spider-man 4 but the big
thing that's going on this week in the
spider-man universe beyond this teaser
is is the spider-man far from homes
social embargo is gonna be up on
Wednesday I'm supposed to see the movie
this week meaning that I can do non
spoilery reaction posts on social media
so it sounds like Marvel is intending on
releasing some big information about a
new spider-man project right after
people are going crazy about Spider Man
far from home just to piggyback on all
the awareness and all the noise going
around spider-man
from home it makes sense like you have
this giant movie everybody's paying
attention to spider-man things and
thinking about the character why
wouldn't you try to announce some
special new spider-man project this is a
clip of Tobey Maguire talking about
spider-man for just a couple days before
they cancelled the movie they were
getting ready to supposedly start
shooting it in 2010 but if you remember
they wound up canceling that rebooting
the character with Andrew Garfield so
this is him just a couple days before
they cancel that movie
and just doing the two pictures in
between prepare you to jump back into
the giant machinery of doing a fourth
movie yeah it's it's great and the
change of perspective is it different
going in or well it's always different I
mean it you know each movie's different
we evolve as people all of that at the
same time there are certain dynamics and
relationships that have continuity you
know Sam and myself Sam Raimi the
director and when we have a a certain
banter or dynamic that that's fun and
funny and I love collaborating with him
so there's some familiarity that I
really love and also I like the new and
okay how do we how do we press this how
do we make it more exciting more fun how
do we evolve the character and make it a
rich story and how do I make it
interesting for myself to go do
something else you know so yeah I
appreciate that too I have fun with
those movies I really do so
heartbreaking watching that if you're a
big fan of Tobey Maguire spider-man
films spider-man 2 is still one of my
favorites spider-man films and it's
still one of the best comic book films
of all time but what was supposed to
happen with spider-man 4 is that it
looked like they were gonna lose their
Uncle Ben cameos the actor that played
him wasn't gonna be available for the
movie and they might also have lost
Kirsten Dunst and they couldn't bring
back James Franco because they killed
him off during spider-man 3 so because
they didn't have Harry Osborn and they
didn't have Mary Jane they were gonna
introduce Felicia Hardy black cat the
vulture was going to be the main villain
and he was going to lead a sinister six
team the lizard dr. Curt Connors from
the previous spider-man films was going
to turn evil as the lizard there would
be a small romance arc with Felicia
Hardy's black cat
she would flip sighs she'd be a little
bit evil a little bit good during the
movie the vulture would be responsible
for creating electro so that character
would happen you can see that they
reused a lot of these ideas for Andrew
Garfield's amazing spider-man like they
did full-on lizard then they did electro
they did a bit of a team-up and amazing
spider-man 2 but they were also going to
do Mysterio which they're finally doing
now but it was going to be Bruce
Campbell so it was gonna be a slightly
older version of Quentin Beck I'm gonna
try and make it more intimate find the
heart of what made spider-man great
originally in the comic books I'm gonna
try and return to the central core of
the character that I fell in love with
and that way I try and make it better
they had done a little bit of
pre-production those are actual
storyboards from the movie and this is a
portion of the script that I'll read
here so this is only a couple pages but
it sets the background for what was
going on during spider-man 4 so the
mysterious plot of spider-man 4 becomes
known while I'm reading from this I'll
cobble together and edit with images
from Tobey Maguire spider-man films so
it makes a little more sense we open up
in the sky a feather falls to the ground
just as it does a slew of bank robbers
pour out as they look up at spider-man
swinging down gracefully landing in a
spider-like position he beats down the
criminals as the cops arrived and the
webhead swings into the alleyway he
removes his mask revealing to us to be
Peter Parker Parker enters the Daily
Bugle to reveal that JJ has been removed
his editor in adriano tooms has taken
his place the vulture tombs is a
hardened bold and scared man who also
doesn't have a sense of humor by night
tooms turns into the vulture and begins
to rob many banks across the city by
morning the headline spreads across the
city quick backstory John Malkovich was
going to play the vulture in this movie
so picture John Malkovich when you're
thinking of Adrian Toomes spider-man
begins to investigate the case with a
utility belt that is equipped with a
mini crime case he Yanks out a small
magnifying glass and starts out over the
scene of the crime
he notices the feather he picks it up
spider-man swings into the ESU
University at the ding of midnight
scrolling over the feather using a DNA
scanner machine Parker finds out that
the DNA belongs to Adrian Toomes the
next day Mary Jane calls Peter for lunch
to meet her real father Peter arrives at
the Louvre kitchen with a suit clearly
not fit for him accompanied with a stash
of roses he dropped
them at the sight of her father Adrian
Toomes both Peter in tombs shake hands
this being an awkward scene we move our
cut to Peter and MJ's new penthouse
apartment the two are arguing over the
idea that the man can't be trusted and
that in fact he is the vulture Mary Jane
leaves an anger so they're already
changing the comics quite a bit like
Adrian Toomes vulture is not Mary Jane's
father but then in the next part of the
story Adrian Toomes winds up causing an
accident at electro Corp and creates the
max Dillon version of electro then he
slowly puts together his sinister six
team so it would have been John
Malkovich leading a version of that team
the way they were going to explain the
spider-man black cat romance during the
events of spider-man 4 is that Mary Jane
was going to leave Peter Parker and move
to Los Angeles to become an actress so
he was going to be single then a little
bit of time goes by and he catches
Felicia Hardy black cat committing a
crime they wind up in bed together that
begins their relationship and then she
winds up trying to help him take down
the sinister six I don't really know if
people would have been willing to accept
that love triangle with black cat and
Mary Jane after they spent so much time
developing that Mary Jane relationship
and all the drama and all the weird
stuff that happened during spider-man 3
what ended up happening though is the
big third-act twist is the black cat was
going to secretly betray spider-man
because Adrian Toomes had been holding
her sister hostage so it would have been
this big double-cross she Yanks the rug
out from under him but then triple
crosses the vulture later and helps
spider-man take him down they wind up
winning by the end of the movie but then
Peter apologizes to Aunt May for all
these problems he's been causing and he
finds out that Mary Jane still wants to
be with him in Los Angeles so remember
in spider-man 2 when he threw the
costume in the trash right out of the
comic books spider-man no more he does
the same thing off the Brooklyn Bridge
he throws the mask off the Brooklyn
Bridge then goes to Los Angeles to be
with Mary Jane the reason why that movie
didn't get made is as Sam Raimi felt
like they never cracked the script they
went through three different writers so
by the time it was getting ready to
shoot he told Amy Pascal who's been
there spider-man person producer at Sony
for a long time that he didn't want to
have another spider-man 3 situation and
make a disappointing movie so he told
Amy Pascal to go ahead and reboot the
Spider Man character like they'd already
been
to do and that's where you get to
amazing spider-man with Andrew Garfield
which they announced just a little while
after that what an interesting thought
that they had actually been planning on
rebooting spider-man as far back as
spider-man 3 so they had been developing
spider-man 4 while they were planning on
rolling out Andrew Garfield amazing
spider-man
I think Sony was just waiting to see if
Sam Raimi was just going to unfurl some
masterpiece of spider-man for us like oh
okay we'll make this instead of doing
Andrew Garfield but they wanted to have
Andrew Garfield waiting in the wings
just in case that didn't work out which
obviously did not in Sam Raimi later
actually reacted to Tom Hollands
recasting too he was actually
surprisingly happy with the idea to take
the character back to high school do a
much younger version of spider-man and
I'm really glad that Marvel's taking it
to high school I think that's going to
be refreshing and just like my favorite
of the spider-man comic books and I have
a lot of faith that they really know
their stuff if you guys didn't see this
morning Marvel and CB Sapolsky
were tweeting out a new spider-man
specific teaser with a three meaning
that this really is a countdown to
something that's going to end on
Thursday the day after the social media
embargo is up for spider-man far from
home he says that it's not going to be a
fantastic four crossover and obviously
he's joking that it's not also going to
be the story of spider-man 4 in a comic
book form but it will be a comic book
project because they have the hashtag
Marvel Comics so whatever this
spider-man property is going to be it's
going to be a comic book everyone post
your theories in the comments below and
let me know what you think about the
planned plot for spider-man 4 but
reading that it's really easy to
understand why Sam Raimi felt like he
didn't quite have the movie script
locked down there'll be a whole bunch
more spider-man stuff posting this week
for spider-man far from home I've also
got some Avengers endgame deleted scenes
with Iron Man and Doctor Strange that I
might post later today as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see the video when I post it and
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
that while you wait for everything click
here for a bunch of deleted scenes and
alternate ending for Avengers and game
in that big final battle and click here
for my last big spider-man far from home
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you